I've talked on the show before about
incidents of anti-jewish anti-semitic
bias that I've experienced they told the
story of once when I was working at
Circuit City when the now-defunct
electronics chain a co-worker of mine
came over and said huh man these
customers I was just dealing with they
were just so Jewish of course my ears
perk up right away and I say what do you
what do you mean what do you mean that
they were so Jewish that they were just
they were trying to Jew me down on the
prices and you know they were just so
difficult to work with and I said oh you
know I'm actually Jewish and he said oh
I'm sorry I shouldn't have said that in
front of you then that is one of the
incidents that really stands out in my
mind and I've got probably a dozen or
more of these incidents have been
involved with and the good thing is that
to some degree and maybe this is because
of the people I surround myself with
I've experienced fewer of these
incidents over time and I'd like to
think that at least in part it's not
necessarily because these beliefs don't
exist anymore recent surveys we've
talked about show that they do exist but
because people at least have more shame
about openly expressing them there's a
recent report from the anti-defamation
league called anti-semitic targeting of
journalists during the 2016 presidential
campaign and what we saw because of the
Donald Trump campaign is a really really
disgusting and wretched resurgence not
necessarily of anti-semitic beliefs
because those have been around for a
very long time but of the willingness to
publicly express that anti-semitism one
of the most targeted Jewish journalists
by those associated loosely as Trump
supporters has been ben shapiro who's
actually a conservative who was not
particularly warm on donald trump he was
heavily targeted by anti-semitic tweets
and images and memes and attacks on the
internet and we also talked about the
campaign of trump itself tweeting this
image of hillary clinton next to a Star
of David with a whole bunch of money a
pile of money in the background all of
this stuff you need to be prepared for
the reality that on display public
anti-semitism is going to have a
significant resurgence under President
Donald Trump we saw an incident in fact
yesterday morning anti-semitic graffiti
and a swastika and the
Sieg Heil 2016 were on a storefront
glass window in South Philadelphia this
is from from what I understand a Jewish
owned business and the reality is that
this is going to be more and more
prevalent these views have been
emboldened consider the alt-right we
actually good opportunity to preview
this we have a really good video about
this movement called the alt-right which
was in great part responsible for the
rise of Donald Trump we've got a
long-form video about the alt-right
coming soon which is a movement that is
highly anti-semitic and highly
supportive of Donald Trump and remember
Jews are the number one victims of
religious hate crimes in the United
States and it is about to get much worse
I've been speaking to people from
different Jewish community groups I've
been speaking to people from the
anti-defamation league and this is
ramping up they are ramping up
preparedness security resources this is
a real problem right this is not one of
these you know I wonder what might
happen we've seen what will happen under
the rhetoric of a Donald Trump during
the campaign we've seen remember that
article I forget what magazine it was in
but Melania Trump was interviewed in a
magazine I don't remember if it was
Vanity Fair or Esquire I apologize that
I don't remember the article and shortly
after that the author of that article
who happens to be Jewish although that
was not a relevant part of the content
of the article was slammed and attacked
all over the internet because they were
Jewish
with anti-semitic tirades diatribes and
epithets and prepare yourselves this is
happening this is real and Pat it's
probably not the only group a lot of a
lot of groups are going to be sort of
fair game for targeting now under the
Trump administration Jews just one of
the ones that have been most visibly
targeted already but a lot of groups
need to be ready we've heard mostly
about how Muslims will be treated under
a trump administration because at one
point he argued that a whole group of
people based on their religion should
not be allowed in the country yeah which
is completely antithetical to the United
States values our Constitution we have
as much about how Judaism will be
treated but now that the altar rites
voice has kind of been legitimized with
his election we'll have to see yeah no
doubt about it it's going to get ugly
ladies and gentlemen of course
overwhelmingly Jews voting for Hillary
Clinton not for Donald Trump